[Applause]
chloe bailey looked heavenly flying onto
the stage for her ama's debut
performance blessing us all with have
mercy
[Music]
[Applause]
the 23 year old looked hot with her
fiery red locks and white embellished
bodysuit thank you now you know chloe
couldn't give us have mercy without
taking a moment to work it on stage
[Applause]
yes the singer put down her mic and
showed the world exactly why we're all
saying
i feel like this is like a vma night
part two et spoke with chloe's sister
halle backstage at the show about how
her sister planned to top her vma
performance of have mercy back in
september which marked her debut
performance as a solo artist i think
because my sister is so amazing at
everything she does she constantly is
trying to one-up herself
and i think that's the beautiful
challenge of a night like this another
big night like this where she can just
give it her all and do twice as amazing
which is hard to do because she's
excellent at everything talk about
sister love and support i am so proud of
my sister tonight et also caught up with
the triple threat ahead of her ama's
performance where she gushed about the
significance of her big night i remember
when sis and i came in the audience
years ago to the amaze and now being
able to be up here and perform my single
and i just put it out like two months
ago yeah it's crazy and i just can't
wait for more the sky's the limit we're
still no release date for the new album
yet right no not yet when is that bad
[ __ ] energy coming oh it's coming it's
already here boo i know it's here but we
want the full pack she's like i'm gonna
change the subject right now we're gonna
talk no no no my nails were like but it
matches i know it looks great
back to the fashion really quick what is
the secret about this look oh the secret
well boob
boot tape yeah a little shimmer shine
okay it's like classic chic and it's
really fun it's simple and you just did
a juice cleanse didn't you oh i did you
saw my tweets i started a month ago i
had to get snatched real quick how did
it go i think it you know the second day
was hell but i made it and i'm here and
i'm eating now yes and yes all events
now how will you celebrate tonight when
the night's over and your work's done
i'm going to get a cinnabun from
cineholic
it's the best vegan cinnabon spot um and
i'm just gonna eat a lot and then work
out hard in the morning because i'm
trying to be snatched now
well i'm coming with you i'm gonna put
this mic down i'm coming with you we're
gonna go get some cinnabon boom thank
you okay have so much money
[Music]